the basic equation for sine and cosine
the general equation is this one here a
which is the amplitude B which is
related to the period through this
formula 2 pi divided by B okay period is
2 P H and K H is the horizontal shift K
is the vertical shift okay and that's
pretty much yet let's take a look at
this example here so you can kind of
understand this a little bit better
first thing I like to do is draw a graph
so PI over 4 count of 5 okay that's
going to be the maximum so I'm just
going to put that right here so 1 2 3 4
5 ok so it's PI over 4 and I'm just
gonna label that PI over 4 comma 5 and
then the minimum over here is at PI over
2 ok which is right here PI over 2 and
that's at negative 1 so that's going to
be right basically there so PI over 2
comma negative 1 and our graphs gonna
look something like this is gonna go
down like that
and back like that ok so you understand
so it has that S shape you know graph
that sine cosine sinusoidal look right
at snake type type look ok so the next
thing we want to do now is we want to
decide ok we're gonna do a sine graph or
a cosine graph well for these ones I
think sometimes it's easier just to do a
cosine graph because you're given the
maximum and normally we graph cosine it
starts at the maximum ok goes down and
comes back up and that's one period so
let's go ahead and start with the cosine
graph I'll show you how to find the sine
graph as well and we'll take a look at
that
so the first thing is to find the the
amplitude now to find the amplitude
we're trying to find the height of these
waves right but you want to measure from
the midline so the way to do that is you
take the maximum value minus the minimum
value divided by two and then you take
the absolute value so we're going to
take five minus negative one okay so
amplitude equals 5 minus negative one
divided by two take the absolute value
so that's six divided by two which is
three and so so far we've got let's see
we've got y equals 3 cosine ok now I
want to find the period one thing I want
you to notice is that when they give us
the maximum the minimum see that
horizontal distance from PI over 4 to PI
over 2 if we subtract that gives us PI
over 4 but that's only half the
period the other half here I drew in and
so what you want to do is you want to
take that and double it so PI over four
doubled gives us PI over two so that
means our B value is PI over two
okay which means I'm sorry our period is
PI over two so we'd have solve for a B
value we've got PI over two equals two
PI over B and if we cross multiply you
get four pi equals PI B and if you
divide by a PI you can see that B equals
4 so we have 4 and then we want to take
into account the you know the phase
shift so the left and right shift
normally this point would be starting
over here okay right at the y-axis so
you can see it's being shifted right PI
over 4 so this is going to be X minus PI
over 4 and if you want to find the
vertical shift okay up or down you can
use this formula for K Max Plus the min
divided by 2 so I'm gonna take the
y-values 5 plus negative 1 okay so 5
plus negative 1 divided by 2 so that
comes out to 2 so that's our K value
okay so that means that this is going to
be plus 2 and I'm just going to draw
this midline in here
y